So, we've learned about
directions requests.
How can we use this within our app?
How about after users register locations
within a certain journey time from work,
we show them the route.
Okay, so we're going to
expand what we did last time.
After the user looks for listings within
a 30 minute walk of their office say,
we'll add a button inside that info
window that appears to allow them to
display the route that
they would take to work.
The first thing we'll do is add
a button that says view route inside
the little info window that appears
when we search for places near work.
This button will point to a new
function called displayDirections,
which we'll create below.
If you remember from last time,
we could have multiple listings
that fall within our commute limit.
So for each button we make,
we'll pass in that origin.
We have some funky quotes here so
that we can pass in
the string correctly as well.
The origin that's passed
is the listings address,
and the destination we'll use
is the user rendered address.
Now we'll create our display
directions function.
This will actually calculate
the directions and
display the route on the map.
We'll initialize a new direction
service instance for this,
just like the rest of our services.
We'll recapture the user-entered
destination and travel mode.
We'll then calculate the route,
passing in the origin,
the destination and the travel mode.
When we get back the response, we'll
make sure that the status is okay, and
then we'll create a new
directions renderer.
Remember the detailed steps and
polyline from the web service response?
This renderer takes care of
displaying that information.
Now at this point, we could display
the route data to the user.
We would just need to specify
the HTML div to put the route in
by setting the panel parameter
in the directions renderer.
There are some good examples of this in
our developer documentation linked in
the instructor notes.
I'm not going to do that, because I
don't think our user needs to see
the step by step
directions in this case.
But we are going to display
the resulting polyline on the map.
I'm going to specify to
render that on our map.
I'm going to tell it to get
the directions from our route response,
and I'm going to specify that I want
the route to be dragable and green.
If the routing was not successful,
we're going to let the user know and
show them the status
code from the response.
Okay, let's look for the listings within
the 30 minute walk of my office again.
I'm going to view the root for this one.
So going from our listing to the office,
it looks like I would
walk down 16th street.
And I think that would take me past
a crepe place which would be awesome.
We'll talk more later about this,
but there are some specific
features that you only get access to by
purchasing a Google Maps API license.
I'm going to cover one of those features
now in our direction's request that
falls in to that category.
Real time traffic integration or
predictive traffic time allows
us to specify additional things and
get back the predicted time in traffic.
This is great for traffic heavy areas,
since the time in traffic
can be drastically different
from the time without.
If we add the driving options
parameter into the request,
obviously the travel mode has to be
driving for this to be effective.
We have the option to
specify a departure time,
which is pretty cool if I want to give
users as an example the option of
calculating a travel time en route
to the airport on Monday mornings.
We can also specify a best guess,
optimistic or pessimistic traffic model,
which can give us the routes and
travel times during lighter or
heavier traffic days.
Users may want to see a pessimistic
value if they're the nervous Nellie type
and want to be at the airport early.
Feel free to check out the video link
in the Instructor Notes on predictive
traffic time.
We won't include that
in our app right now.
Let's test out some route
optimization using direction service